guided by moonlight punong tribe head
into the mountains as most of taejun
city sleeps
hundreds of them are taking part in the
malahudaijan festival the ear shooting
ceremony an annual celebration honoring
both hunter and wild game
for centuries their ancestors hunted for
food
they no longer need to but are desperate
to keep what's left of their traditions
and culture alive
we used to live high up in the mountains
and needed to hunt to survive
but the government over time moved us
down and out of the mountains
we still hunt because that's what our
ancestors have been doing all along
while hunting is no longer for survival
the indigenous people of taiwan are
battling against government-imposed
hunting limitations including
only being allowed to use homemade guns
and the need for prior hunting approvals
on friday taiwan's constitutional court
will decide
if these limitations are discriminatory
and unconstitutional
we hope the courts will finally legalize
hunting rifles which are safer than
forcing us to use antique homemade
muskets
it's not the animals that will get hurt
it's us the aboriginal hunters
in 2013 tamar taloon was jailed for
three and a half years on weapon
and poaching charges the sentence
angered his punong tribe one of 16
officials recognized indigenous groups
in taiwan
for thousands of years they hunted and
fished with little interference but
colonialism and modernisation pushed
them off their lands
today there are little over half a
million indigenous people in taiwan
and that's two percent of the island's
mostly ethnic hand chinese population
in 2016 president saying when formally
apologized to the indigenous groups for
centuries of
pain and mistreatment an unprecedented
move as a self-governed territory which
is claimed by china
carves its own identity away from the
mainland
despite that economic and social
marginalization created an indigenous
rights movement especially among the
youth
my grandfather and father taught me what
i know i watched and learned
they taught me knowledge and wisdom but
i fear many of those will not be passed
on
and will disappear
activists say the court's outcome on how
gun control and wildlife conservation
laws should be balanced could have major
implications for indigenous rights in
taiwan
they say they hope game hunting will be
recognized as a culture
and not a crime
al jazeera